Mà mang in không tra mình sau đánh giấu 2 năm, chúng chính tiếp sức một thí được chín khai trên phạm bị tòn quốc.
Chuy chính năm, anh nhận hơn 2 năm nìn lượt tăng kỹ thăm ra,
có đó tuyển trọng hơn 6 hình dình viên tình huyệt.
Hỗ trợ tại 2 chăm 4 miếng sau điểm thí trên bị bản thình phố chí mêng.
Theo bản tổ chất, các đổi hình tình huyệt sẽ chín khai nhau đậm hộ chở trước trong và sau khi thí.
Như là từ bản thủ nghiệp, hỗ trợ tâm liy, hưởng giận thị sinh tại điểm thí,
sở cấp cử, điều phối sau thông và phát tạng và phẩm thiết iếu.
Để nay chúng chính này tổ chất tạm miếng tương hoạt động tư vấn cho 1 năm nìn học xanh.
Và thành năm mình in cầm năng hướng nghiệp.
Dịp này thì bản tổ chức cũng chào 1 năm sốt học bà 1 trong xin có hình cạnh khó khăn.
Và vận động hàng chục nghiệp phần qua hỗ trợ tí xanh trong 1 thí năm này.